[Music]
hi my name is Stefan I'm at the digital
analytics faculty chair for simply
learning in my consulting practice I get
to work with amazing science of Vargus 5
some startups and some established
organizations different verticals
different geographies small and large
digital analytics and digital marketing
teams throughout the years I've done a
number of things like publishing the
digital analytics maturity model and
more recently the radical analytics
manifesto and I have developed tools and
concepts that are recognized and renown
in the industry I play different roles
either on the agency side on the client
side
I've been advising to startups in the
field an established organization in a
digital analytics industry I'm also
speaking at different conferences in
Europe and North America and I'm
teaching for simply learning and other
universities welcome to advanced digital
analytics my name is Stefano male
faculty chair for digital antics I
simply learn we're going to start with
lesson number one an introduction to
digital analytics
we're going to start by defining the
turns analytics and analysis we want to
look at the various types of analytics
that we can do depending on our level of
maturity and the type of business
questions that we want to answer and
we're going to have a brief overview of
how we're going to use Google Analytics
and in real-life environments so that
you can actually apply the concepts
we're going to see throughout the course
start by defining what is digital
analytics simply put digital analytics
is the science of analysis with a
greater focus on Internet data it
involves the collection the analysis
visualization and hopefully data
informed decisions leading to the
optimization of the organization either
Digital Ecosystem but we'll see that we
want to expand that eventually to
encompass more than just Digital
Ecosystem but also any order supporting
business processes that are involved in
that digital ecosystem
so in the past we were talking about web
analytics but this definition of webinar
takes was a little bit too centric
around web data today what we're looking
at is digital analytics because it
includes data coming from of course
mobile applications social media and
third-party data source but maybe more
importantly it also involves eventually
connecting the behavior that you see
throughout those different internet
devices with web mobile application
social media Internet of Things and so
on but we want to tie that to core
business data about customers and cells
so we have at our fingertips a lot of
information coming from different data
points we can combine that that
information with sales or customer so
that we not only look at the marketing
aspects of leveraging the data but also
any other business function that are
involved in optimizing and understanding
customer behavior be it online or
offline so we're going to see in this
course how we can use data to better
inform business decisions
so why is the design antics so important
well you you could look at your own
experience it is very very useful it's
very valuable but it's your own
experience with all the bias but also
the scalability issues so you cannot
transpose your own experience to other
people you can coach them you can help
them but it remains your own experience
so digital antics approach will help
share that knowledge amongst your
stakeholders and your claims faith is
sometimes you have a very very strong
belief that if we do this the result
should be that but unless you actually
measure it and test it you can be sure
and it's very closely related to the
third point which is the assumption it's
quite possible that if you do a the
result would be B that makes sense right
in a given context the problem is things
are changing very rapidly so what was
true maybe a couple of months ago might
not be true anymore so we live in an era
where we need to constantly measure
optimize and adapt to the changing
landscape so in all those aspects
digital analytics is going to help you
better understand better react and make
decisions and share the knowledge and
information you have about what's going
on
so let's define what is analytics
analytics is the science of analysis so
we're going to have to define what is
analysis if we want to call it a science
so in the past there were different
definitions of what is digital nowadays
from the digital analytics Association
from Avinash Kaushik and other people
but they want to prefer it this one
analytics is how an organization arrives
at an optimal and realistic decision
informed by data and what's nice about
this definition is that we can clearly
define each of those terms and why they
are important in that definition so
let's look at organization it doesn't
matter if it's a private or a publicly
traded company doesn't matter if it's a
start-up or a well established
organization doesn't matter if it's
government academic profit or nonprofit
it could even be a subgroup within a
larger company so we want to look at how
this group this organization is able to
leverage data to make better informed
decisions the how implies that there's a
process there's a workflow there's a way
to get there we're trying to answer a
specific business question the arrived
also implies that we start from
somewhere and we want to get to an
answer a solution the optimal and
realistic are super important the
optimal is what would be the best
solution regardless of the constraints
but realistically there's always
constraints of these budget resources
time tools technology legal aspects or
just ethical aspects that come into play
and politics of course so we want to
find a balance between what would be the
best solution versus what realistic lis
we can do and often time I see analysts
making recommendation that would be
fantastic but there are so many
constraints that realistically it cannot
be done so if we find the right balance
between the two there wouldn't be any
excuse not to do it the other term is
informed we often hear the term
data-driven
and I believe that we should talk about
being data informed because the data
itself doesn't make any decision it
doesn't do anything we need to be
informed in order to make a decision and
the data notice that I don't mention
digital data I don't mention the source
because frankly it doesn't matter where
the data is coming from as long as it's
relevant and useful and appropriate to
answer the business question we have so
it could be coming from the web of
course but it could be coming from other
sources like social media even
competitive analysis and of course your
back office systems
so if analytics is the science of
analysis what is analysis analysis is
the process of breaking something
complex into smaller parts so that we
can understand how it works and if we
understand how it works we can measure
it and we can optimize it so this is
going to be very important throughout
the course because instead of aiming to
optimize a single thing by a thousand
percent which would be very very
difficult why don't we try to optimize a
thousand things by just 1% each so you
could imagine that trying to optimize a
single thing by a thousand person is
very risky the likelihood of succeeding
is above zero while expending a lot of
different things a lot of smaller things
because you broke it apart into smaller
parts you can easily go and improve by
one person and the effect of this
approach is more agile approach is going
to be that as soon as you start to
provide a small one person improvement
there's going to be an exponential curve
of all the improvements we're going to
make over time and you start basically
to get the benefits sooner and faster
because you're working on things that
are easier to manage
so there are three super important
elements of analytics the first one the
very first one is what is the context of
your analysis what is the problem you're
trying to solve what is the opportunity
you're trying to capture the other one
is data of course you need data in order
to understand what's going on measure it
make sense of it find the patterns in
the correlations and so on and ELQ you
make a recommendation that makes sense
and that's where you need to be creative
because you you cannot just look at your
competitors and say oh look at what they
are doing we could do the same no you
need to be more creative to that in
order to do better there's a lot of room
for creativity in analytics and you need
to be creative in the way that you find
ideas for your recommendations
now let's look at the different types of
analytics what you get out of a tool
like Google Analytics is descriptive
analytics you can look at what happened
so you pick a date range you look at the
report you understand what happened
so essentially anyone can go in a tool
and get those numbers where you bring
value as an analyst is in diagnostic and
analytics you want to understand why it
happened so you're not looking at a tool
you're looking at the context of the
business you're looking at trying to
make sense of all the data source that
you can get so already there you move
from the tools centricity and the
channel centric approach of being web to
something that would shift and try to
understand why are my customers behaving
in this way and not in the way I expect
them then this is still information this
is still very valuable to make better
informed decisions but as you grow in
maturity you're going to grow into
optimization and you're going to look at
what may happen in the future so you can
do predictive analytics you can even go
beyond that and do prescriptive
analytics so when you reach that level
of certification there's obviously more
value but it's also more complex so I
think you need to mass order the first
levels before you reach prescriptive
analytics where what you want to do is
prevent bad things from happening and
hopefully you know capture the good
things that could happen in the future
so keep in mind what's important here is
that when you go into a tool and you get
those reports what you do is descriptive
analytics if you just provide those
numbers you don't have a lot of value
the value you bring is looking at why it
happened and understand the conditions
of why it happened and how you can
optimize that
so is it really difficult to start in
digital antics that's one of the
question I get very often no it's really
really easy there are free tools like
Google Analytics that you can start with
then and a lot of others and you so it's
easy and affordable to start but one of
the things that you should do is assess
your maturity level what are your
strengths and weaknesses
what are your understanding of the
concepts of digital analytics and we're
going to talk more about maturity in the
upcoming lessons but one of the key
point is also to first focus on what you
can control
manage and influence what you control
are basically the tasks that you're
supposed to do right now are you able to
do those tasks efficiently do you have
the right tools you have the right
knowledge so this is great because it's
an area we want to do what we preach we
try to measure and optimize the business
so maybe the starting point is to
measure and optimize what we do in our
own tasks as an analyst or as a marketer
then manage if you're in a management
position you are in charge of delivering
some value to the organization you are
empowered to do it so you can assign the
resources in order to make it happen and
if you have some influence maybe you are
considered as a subject matter expert
and those could be areas where
eventually you could grow and have more
influence and take more ownership or
more of working things to do analysis
for those other aspects of the business
regardless of what they might be but the
key point here is start with the things
that you control start with the things
that you are already supposed to do and
try to optimize those things as your own
job keep in mind that analysts are
change agents and we're going to come
back to this topic later on in the
course but Adam is our change agents so
imagine an organization that claims to
be data-driven but every time they are
presented some data and some facts the
there's a lot of resistance to change
and they don't change anything so you
would wonder why do they do an entity
from the first place they are just
wasting their time so doing analytics
and
plies that you are willing to take risks
you are willing to learn you are willing
to make changes although I don't do it
so of course this course is not about
Google antics I will not show tricks and
tips to use a specific tool but we want
to present you with the concepts of
digital analytics and there's of course
a lot of things that we can show in the
slides and so on but one of the best way
to learn is to actually try it and we're
lucky to be able to use Google Analytics
and the Google merchandise store which
is a real live store selling goods and
clothing and gadgets and so on branded
items for Google so you will have access
to this data I really encourage are
strongly encouraging you to get ready go
into Google Analytics learn about visit
the Google merchandise store play around
with it and you will have access to the
data and I will help you go through the
exercise of what we're going to be
presenting in each lesson in order to
get access to the Google annex data the
Google merchandise store you can just
follow that link and you will get all
the instructions to access it
a couple of key takeaways for this first
lesson and then it takes is only
possible given a context given access to
some relevant data and being creative in
the way not only the way you conduct
your analysis but also in the way that
you make your recommendations and then
it involves breaking a complex topic
into smaller cards this will help you
understand measure and optimize digital
analytics is not only about the web it's
about understanding business context
again getting the right data and
oftentimes yes the data is coming from
web but it's certainly not the only
source of data that you might need in
order to do your analysis and understand
the business process and make better
informed decisions the field of digital
analytics has grown to be very complex
so one way to overcome that complexity
is really to instead of trying to change
the world and change the whole organs
that you're involved with start by the
things that you control and try to
optimize that before you venture into
influencing more changes in the
organization use a digital analytics
maturity assessment to find what are
your strengths and weaknesses and from
that you're going to be able to create a
better roadmap a more realistic roadmap
so we're going to look at the maturity
assessment in one of the upcoming lesson